Can Hoist doesn't, you know,
at this point when you compare,
compare to these athletic guys and
MMA today we saw it with Matt Hughes,
you know, you know, he
couldn't compete anymore. Um,
once people sort of knew
the tricks. But um, yeah,
I mean that it's very humbling.
The whole experience. Even crazier.
Hixon hoists his brother voice will
tell you he's 10 times better than him.
Yeah. Hixon would do to hoists what hoists
would do to other black belts. Well,
wasn't that select the,
uh,
the story was they could have had Hixon
but he was too athletic and two s,
you know,
there was a bunch of issues and I would
not want to say exactly what happened
for fear of upsetting either side, cause
I think there's two different stories.
Okay. But, uh, he was essentially
the champion of the family.
And one of the thoughts was that it would
be a more impressive if hoist did it
because her voice was only 175 pounds
and with his shirt off and he looked like
he was fit but look like a volleyball
player or something. Right. Whereas Hicks,
like Freddie Mercury, Hickson
was shredded. It takes him,
was like really into physical training.
He did a lot of gymnastics and yoga.
He was unbelievably athletic. Yeah. But
he was also like way physically stronger.
It would appear more that he was
just dominating some like a cat.
He would jump on. So it wasn't
as good of an advertisement for,
it wasn't necessarily true though,
because there was also talked that no
one can control Hicks and it didn't want
Hixon to win. Cause Hixon is
a, he's like a free spirit,
like in the greatest sense of the word.
Like legitimately he might throw his phone
in the ocean to disappear for a month
and just fucking surf and do
Jiu Jitsu somewhere. Oh he's,
he's a freak in the best sense
of the word. That's awesome.
So I don't think they ever thought they
could control Hixon that was part of the
problem with having Hicks
and be the champion.
Hixon would probably freeze up the
whole organization. I want $10 million,
I'll never fight again.
Right.
Like they were offering him fights for
years and he had some crazy number that
he wanted and he was like, if you give
me that number, I'll fight for a door.
If you give me that number, I'll fight
the best fighters in the, Oh yeah,
it's after. After the Oct, right?
Yes. What after the UFC started,
but everybody's still knew. See when
hoists was winning, everyone's still new.
Hickson was competing in something
called Japan Valley Tudo and one that you
have to see the super high level
Jujitsu pride. One was Hixon, um,
and uh,
Hickson was the guy that everybody knew
that if something happened and then
hoists was out of the UFC or there
was no other, uh, Gracie's in the UFC,
Hixon is always there to step in.
And we were always wondering,
when is he gonna step down? When's it
gonna Fight? The best guys never did. No,
he fought.
He fought foo knocky who was a really
high level guy that was his last fight and
he strangled him, uh, put them to sleep.
It's crazy image man of him. Rear naked,
choke,
finicky,
and for Nike's eyes roll in the back
of his head and he goes unconscious and
Hickson just throws him off.